and clipped her with a car and she was
[ __ ] up
i mean she was she went from being a
straight a student to being someone who
could no longer do math
she detailed it like really emotionally
and and very honestly and vulnerably
she was very vulnerable in discussing it
on my podcast it was really scary
she she's got such a big heart too it
really is very
very obvious whenever she talks and
she's on twitter and she's super funny
uh i i mean i'm a big fan of her twitter
and well and that thing that she said
about that woman
you know being a marriage of this and
you know muslim
brotherhood you know like that ain't the
worst thing to say
and the lady looks like the lady from
the planet of the apes i don't give a
[ __ ] what you say
that she does she didn't even know she
was black i thought the [ __ ] was white
two great things she's like she was
jewish she looks like my sister
she's running the government she must be
jewish i i thought the thing that's
great about roseanne is she was on i
think tucker carlson and sean hannity
she looked he's like do you want to
apologize to valerie jarrett
she looked the camera she goes valerie
i'm genuinely sorry
i did not want to hurt you this was not
acceptable but i also do think you need
a better haircut
you know like she still had her joke in
there but she's such a sweetheart
um yeah and and i don't think the thing
that i have people arguing with me about
when valerie jarrett was born iran yes
and people were like well they're
they're
she's not black she was born iran i'm
like you know black people can give
birth in iran right that's the thing and
this was rap they couldn't wrap their
heads around it that she was black but
in iran her parents were american
right yeah yeah the whole thing was a
mess but it's also one of those things
that's fiercely tribal just like you
said before
and then our tribe the tribe of the left
or the tribe of the right
our tribe has decided your tribe is
unacceptable unacceptable in what you've
done is
just beyond the possibility of any sort
of apology
you need to be removed even at a
significant financial loss
and apparently the people that were
responsible for getting her fired one of
them has already been removed oh
yeah and um now they're realizing this
was a horrendous decision they went from
having the number one
show on television to having this
bastard version of the hogan family it's
[ __ ] terrible man and nobody wants it
and
so they if they just decided to bring
her back and she apologized and everyone
soothed it over and
look there could be money donated to
charitable causes it could be a
teachable moment or a learning moment
for for everybody for the whole country
a moment also of like
like of bonding where we just abandoned
these
ridiculous ideas there was an episode i
watched the series
uh like it was like episode six her
neighbors that moved in to the conner's
house were
from lanford were muslims and roseanne
was prejudiced and then she realized she
was wrong
there was an episode that's like stopped
being so she's always been very
culturally left
yeah yeah she she
she is in some ways and she's right in
some but she's
she leans right in some way she's very
pro-israel yes she's like super
so so much so that she's even talked
about moving to israel yes yes
and yeah because i mean i think i think
she feels i i can't speak for her so
yeah well the whole but what do you got
here jamie because the ratings are
actually pretty good
it's the number two show overall in abc
and it's their top-rated comedy
down from where it was obviously but
that's spin though what are you getting
this from
you're getting this from vulture.com
which is a very left-leaning show
and it's probably we'll go to the title
of this go to the title of this all
tv shows right now yeah
murphy brown good lord yeah what uh
what's that about it's a mummy that
comes back to life
yeah but the the the ratings are
significantly lower
more than 50 percent lower than they
were with the other show true but it was
also
an extreme hit right but it's the same
show jamie
okay there's no way you're going to tell
me 50 is not a problem yeah but that's
the problem you're reading a spin
what you're reading is vultures spin on
it that says it's not that bad
they're circling the wagon not only is
it not that bad they did 10 episodes
they ordered
an 11th yes that's unprecedented what
you order is like when i was on sitcoms
they would do a thing called the back
nine
right so you would get 13 episodes and
they would order the back nine which
would bring you to 22 which is a full
order they're not doing a full order
this show's dead
right so it ain't good and the other
thing is you keep in mind
this show is extremely expensive yeah
because you got to pay laurie matcat
who's probably the best comedic actress
out there 300 000 goodman gets more than
300 thousand dollars
sarah gilbert gets more than 300 and
then you've got the others too and
there's
a million dollars right away just with
three members of the cast
then you have production fees all these
other different fees there must be a
billion eps in that show
it's crazy money it's crazy money and it
could be
the biggest show on television if she
was still on it and
and the apology was accepted you're not
going to lose viewers
they could have easily done an episode
where they can't yeah where the
character did that
and the character gets clowned as an
[ __ ] yes a hundred percent
they could have done it where they
they're interviewing her outside of the
polls and she says that
right tv television yeah they say she
says it on television and then she gets
labeled as a racist
and then a bunch of people say well she
really does look like that lady
so that'll be how it ended it would end
with them coming home dan closed the
door and goes through she really does
look like that i know
the whole thing i didn't know she was
black and like how could you not know
and then they show different people that
look black that aren't black
and different people that look white but
are black